[Musique]
Guillaume Meurice bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle thinkerview
mais oui
on aurait aimé un petit peu avoir votre
vision de tout un tas de choses comme
des sujets politiques comment vous
travaillez c'est fou ça mais d'abord
notre première question comment vous
nous connaissez et bah c'est un ami à
moi qui m'a fait découvrir je crois que
la première vidéo que j'ai regardé c'est
Elise Lucet
j'ai un ami qui est fan de vous donc
voilà j'ai regardé Élise Lucet qu'est-ce
que j'ai regardé Paul Watson parce que
je suis assez sensible à la protection
animale etc et puis après voilà une fois
que j'avais un petit peu de temps à pas
à perdre mais à gagner pour le coup j'ai
regardé un peu Jean Lassalle parce que
moi-même j'ai fait une interview de
genre la salle alors je voulais voir
comment ça se passait sur la durée etc
et puis voilà je trouve ça hyper
intéressant et j'aime bien j'aime bien
le style en plus j'aime bien
l'esthétique une vraie esthétique avec
un truc un peu mystérieux parce que vous
le voyez pas en fait
ça explique pas tout ça explique pas
tout
et donc vous travaillez vous travaillez
sur le télé sur le service public France
Inter comment ça s'est goupillé vous
êtes arrivés vous avez fait une demande
on vous a contacté qui est-ce qui est
venu vous chercher alors c'est un peu
tout ça en fait Frédéric Lopez monter
une nouvelle émission Fred avec Lopez
télévision j'emmène Mimi Mathy en terme
inconnu tout ça et il avait une émission
et donc il montait une nouvelle émission
de 11h à 12h30 qui était une émission de
divertissement avec des chroniqueurs et
il voulait je crois des gens de scène et
que des nouvelles voies du coup moi je
correspondais un peu à ça en plus
j'avais un blog très intimiste qui
devait être lu par 50 personnes les
jours de gloire mais j'écrivais les
chroniques d'actu donc j'avais un peu
stropisme là de m'intéresser à la
société quoi et tout bêtement j'ai passé
une audition avec plein de copains
humoristes et ça s'est bien passé j'ai
été embauché
de
fois c'était peut-être 180 euros au
début 180 euros la pige ouais c'est à
l'émission tête de sang
[Musique]
tourne autour de ça ouais ça doit être
ça c'est que dalle ben je sais pas ouais
on me dit les deux en fait moi parce que
c'est que des blagues quand même donc
200 euros pour faire des blagues
franchement ouais non mais je devrais
pas dire ça ouais c'est que dalle ça
scandale c'est scandaleux mais moi je me
dis toujours tu vois c'est de l'argent
public tu as des gens qui savent le
matin qui se crèvent le cul qui font un
taf qu'ils aiment pas moi j'arrive je me
marre avec mes potes j'ai écrit des
blagues bon voilà on a voilà vous faites
quoi à côté pour survivre
bah là et là je suis payé plus
maintenant je paye 240 euros la
chronique parce que je suis tous les
jours et puis l'émission marche bien et
à côté j'ai des spectacles enfin j'ai
mon spectacle société de production
c'est pas moi mais j'ai un producteur
c'est pas mon producteur le spectacle a
un producteur ce que vous avez un jour
senti de la censure sur France Inter non
enfin moi non
est-ce qu'il y en a eu je sais pas
Pierre-Emmanuel barré ouais
Pierre-Emmanuel ouais c'est plus une
histoire de personne c'est avec Nagui ça
a fritté faudrait l'inviter lui demander
dans les détails je veux pas parler à sa
place mais c'était entre les deux tours
l'ambiance était assez tendax quand même
à France Inter et il avait fait une
grosse
Front National au deuxième tour tu vois
tu es un peu quand même tout le monde a
tout le monde est un peu dans ses petits
dans ces petits chaussons quoi mais nous
notre émission elle est l'après-midi
avec Charline et Alex on est assez
protégé de ça parce qu'on n'est pas à la
rédac on a un peu dans notre coin on a
un peu dans notre bureau au pénard donc
nous on a pas tellement ressenti à la
matinale ouais il y avait une espèce de
tension
palpable mais
[Musique]
les gens se marmois sur les papiers
humoristiques ou
les invités sont un peu plus peu plus
sérieux tu sens que l'heure est grave tu
le sens dans les comportements quoi
et puis peut-être voilà peut-être les
humoristes ont ressenti aussi en faisant
leurs papiers moi je suis pas le matin
donc c'est un peu délicat de parler à
place des autres quoi si un jour on te
censure tu fais quoi je partirai je l'ai
déjà fait à Canal en fait j'ai déjà fait
un Canal+ pardon j'avais fait c'était au
moment des attentats le Charlie Hebdo
j'avais une chronique où je finissais
par les saints de Charb et il m'avait
dit non ça va pas être possible pour des
raisons de sécurité
allez dis c'est pas négociable en fait
le mec il est pas enterré donc soit je
la fais comme ça soit je me barre et
j'étais parti après moi je me méfie
quand même pas mal du mot censure
dans le sens où j'ai pas crié à
l'ascension après c'est un choix
éditorial moi l'autocensure
c'est pareil ça je vois faudrait définir
le terme en fait
tu te sens sur tout le temps tu fais les
choix en fait mais ça veut dire quoi sur
ton censuré ça veut dire que tu fais pas
un truc parce que tu as une pression
extérieure ou ta propre pression à toi
qui te dit pas le faire ou tu anticipe
les pressions que tu pourrais subir
non jamais enfin non moi j'ai jamais
subi de pression en fait mais je crois
que je suis pas très dangereux moi en
fait je crois pas que comment tu
pourrais si on peut se tutoyer
comment tu pourrais définir ta
profession humoriste c'est quoi c'est le
saltimbanque du 21e siècle c'est c'est
humoriste oui ou ça parce qu'il faut
bien résumer il faut bien trouver un
terme
est-ce que c'est le salt un manque du
21e siècle mais il y a plusieurs façons
d'aborder l'humour quoi moi je considère
que l'humour c'est un média c'est à dire
c'est pas une fin pour moi
mais c'est un moyen de dire ce que j'ai
envie de dire j'utilise l'humour parce
que c'est naturel pour moi j'ai toujours
été assez déconneurs
si tu veux reprendre depuis le bac de
gestion qui m'a servi à peu près à rien
du tout si ce n'est à bien me marrer
avec mes potes quand j'ai fait mes
études à Besançon et à buzac mec
pas très loin pas très loin passe le
bonjour
salut à toi et après cours Florent je
suis venu j'ai un peu le parcours du mec
qui arrive à Paris avec sa petite valise
c'est un peu le truc un peu romantique
tu sais cours Florent trois ans même 4
j'étais assistant d'une prof après j'ai
fait du spectacle en sortant de cours je
passe les détails je fais un peu
peut-être de rue j'ai gratté un premier
spectacle que j'ai joué pas mal et puis
après il y a eu la radio j'ai écrit un
deuxième spectacle
et puis là il y a la deuxième émission
de radio parce que c'est pas la même
c'est plus celle de Frédéric Lopez comme
tu l'auras compris comment tu fais je
vous écoute
comment tu fais pour construire ta
chronique est-ce que tu fais dire des
recherches est-ce que tu fais du
sourcing est-ce que tu passes des nuits
des nuits dans des bibliothèques sur
internet des choses comme ça ou c'est un
réseau qui t'informe oh non c'est rien
de tout ça en fait parce que comme moi
je me considère pas journaliste au mieux
je suis éditorialiste quoi et je rajoute
et voilà éditorialiste humoristes tu
vois donc
oui je me enfin je trouve un thème
d'actu qui me qui fait écho en moi ou
j'ai eu un truc à dire dessus il me faut
un angle il faut que l'angle soit
humoristique voilà la contrainte est-ce
que la rédaction examine ton travail
mes textes sont pas relu avant l'antenne
l'émission est en direct il y a qu'une
seule personne qui réécoute les sons que
je diffuse c'est la réalisatrice parce
qu'elle fait les niveaux mais non non en
fait je suis jamais sous surveillance
[Musique]
donc j'ai une liberté totale mais encore
une fois je te dis j'ai une liberté
totale parce que même sur des sujets
chauds
[Musique]
pourquoi les gens rigolent non mais ça
dépend quel est ton but quand tu veux
faire rigoler quelqu'un si tu veux faire
rigoler quelqu'un
aux dépens je sais pas moi si on prend
un exemple si tu veux faire des blagues
homophobes dans une chronique genre avec
des nouilles dans ce clip
je sais pas bon ça c'est à chacun de se
démerder mais par exemple si tu fais une
chronique qu'avec des blagues homophobes
[Musique]
par quel vecteur Facebook beaucoup moi
je traîne pas trop sur les commentaires
Twitter ou les commentaires Facebook
m'intéressent pas enfin ça m'intéresse
que les gens ont le droit de s'exprimer
et je pour le coup je sens sur rien sur
ma page mais je vais pas trop je vais
pas trop voir ce qui se dit par contre
les messages privés j'essaie d'y
répondre et en fait plus je devrais pas
le dire parce que du coup après je
reçois beaucoup plus le message est
agressif plus ça m'intéresse de répondre
et donc à un moment d'une façon
agressive tu trouves qu'on t'a contacté
d'une façon agressive
et que je vois passer ton truc tu aurais
commencé par espèce de connard sur je
l'aurais ouvert tes morts ce soir
j'ai bon bah au moment des attentats on
a fait les chroniques avec Mahomet tout
ça donc on a reçu donc je me suis amusé
c'est un peu mon hobby en fait à
répondre
et bon tu as des gens qui sont qui ont
juste besoin de te cracher à la gueule
c'est pas très gênant en fait après tu
as eu une autre catégorie de personnes
c'est les personnes qui ont mal perçu
parce que tu avais à dire donc j'ai
expliqué qu'en fait on était plutôt avec
eux en fait on prenait leur défense dans
le sens où les gens qui travestissent
leur religion c'est les terroristes quoi
après peut-être qu'on travestir sa
religion bah c'est à dire si on prend
l'exemple de l'islam un musulman qui se
sentait offensé par ma chronique par
exemple
je lui ai expliqué que c'est pas ce que
j'avais voulu dire mais peut-être que
c'est moi qui était maladroit en fait
donc juste je te dis moi j'ai rien
contre tu crois en ce que tu veux aux
licornes j'en ai rien à [__] c'est
juste que la chronique n'était pas
adressée à toi
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui t'ont
contacté qui avait été blessés sur leur
convictions leurs valeurs la religion
souvent ça revient ça bah ouais comme
c'est parti politique peut-être tu me
diras si une religion aussi non
elle est pas alors pour finir sur les
religions
tu as toujours la même type de critique
quand tu critiques une religion les la
religion te dit vous auriez pas le faire
sur les sur les autres donc comme j'ai
la chance d'avoir fait beaucoup beaucoup
de chroniques je peux leur envoyer les
chroniques que j'ai fait sur les autres
religions et souvent je me disent pas
après tu tombes sur une chronique sur
facebook tu es pas censé savoir que le
gars ça fait deux ans qu'il en fait tu
vois donc moi j'en veux à personne et je
m'en fous et ta question sur la
politique c'est plus c'est pas pareil
comme ça je joue pas au même endroit
parce que l'humour est efficace pour
militer
ah moi j'aime pas le mot militaire
pourquoi
il y a un côté qui m'emmerde
qui est de vous devez penser ça j'ai
raison de penser ça ce que j'adore moi
c'est l'esprit critique j'aime bien
remettre en cause des trucs en fait ce
que je fais dans mes chroniques
et j'aime bien qu'on le fasse avec moi
et c'est pour ça par exemple que j'ai
accepté ton invitation parce que je sais
d'autres invitation
parce que je sais que vous avez des
questions que voilà cache quoi et on
parle vraiment quoi et non mais ça ça me
plaît vraiment parce que ce que je fais
aux gens ce que je fais subir aux gens
toute la semaine j'adore le débat
j'adore la discussion et j'aime bien ça
donc mon objectif dans une chronique et
pas de dire j'ai raison et si vous
pensez pas ça vous êtes des cons mon
objectif c'est de faire rigoler ça on
l'a bien compris c'est-à-dire si une
chronique est pas marrante je considère
qu'elle est quand même foirée c'est ce
qu'on me demande et ce que j'aime faire
et deuxièmement de donner mon point de
vue sur la chose
des arguments ou des angles de réflexion
des pistes des arguments des
contre-arguments
et voilà et de laisser ouvert le truc
c'est pour ça que je vire pas les
commentaires en dessous mes chroniques
sur Facebook les gens ils se répondent
et tant mieux qui sont pas d'accord avec
moi en fait de débat l'humour vecteur de
débat peut-être plus ça ouais mais
milite
je sais pas peut-être c'est moi qui a un
problème avec le mot en fait est-ce que
est-ce que tu connais d'autres
humoristes à l'international
assez merdique Georges Carlin
explique-nous ce que tu connais ben je
connais j'ai juste l'image d'une grande
gueule qui kiffe en fait c'est l'image
que j'ai après comme je connais très peu
tu vas pouvoir me reprendre dessus c'est
un mec qui fait rigoler en disant la
vérité il y a pas de ce que j'ai vu il y
a pas tellement de Vannes il y a pas
tellement de construction
humoristique quoi et il y a plutôt des
vérités balancées et tout le monde fait
pas normalement on n'a pas le droit de
dire ça mais je connais pas assez pour
développer le truc tu vois de ce que
j'ai vu comment tu l'as connu
on a dû m'envoyer des vidéos où j'ai dû
trouver ça sur Internet ton humoriste
préféré
ça c'est
moi j'aime bien le gorafi par exemple
il y a Corse
des fois ils sont chauds mais
j'aime bien ouais j'aime bien après
c'est doute j'aime bien Alexandre Astier
par exemple mais qui est pas vraiment
considéré comme un humoriste mais j'aime
bien son nuage j'aime bien Édouard
j'aime bien des gens comme ça
tu vois comment ta profession avec
l'état d'urgence
la tension dans le dialogue entre les
gens parce que tu
tu le sens moi je
j'ai une espèce de cap si tu veux que je
tiens donc
j'ai pas j'aime pas me laisser
influencer par tu as froid tu vas
croiser les jambes là non tu as les
jambes croisées
j'ai mal au dos en fait
je peux mettre comme ça si tu veux il
faut que je trouve une position de
confort
donc en fait non ça influe pas je sais
plus quel était ta question est-ce que
ça influe est-ce que
sur mon travail l'état d'urgence comment
tu vois l'humoriste avec une société
civile qui se tend parce que c'est la
crise financière c'est la guerre c'est
les flux migratoires c'est la Syrie
c'est les tensions de la société civile
en fait j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y
ait participation des tensions
non non
beaucoup on joue beaucoup là-dessus à la
télé parce qu'il faut faire du spectacle
faut retenir le spectateur en haleine
en fait moi qui connaît et genre je vais
interroger les gens oui bah en fait je
rencontre très peu de gens haineux pour
te dire très peu de gens tendus comme tu
viens de dire je rencontre beaucoup de
gens qui ont structurellement pas le
temps de se poser la question
de pourquoi il pense ce qu'il pense
c'est à dire je m'explique qu'est-ce que
ça provoque chez toi
ça provoque une grosse envie de
pédagogie
j'ai envie de dire merde arrêtons-nous
cinq minutes calmez-vous calmez-vous
fermez bien tous vos gueules là on va
réfléchir à ce qui est en train de se
passer peut-être que là on est en train
de merder
mais j'en veux jamais aux gens de penser
ce qu'ils pensent moi j'ai je suis ce
que je suis parce que je suis je suis
assez déterminé je suis ce que je suis
parce que je suis le fruit d'une
éducation des rencontres que j'ai fait
je suis pas très tellement responsable
de ce que je pense ou de ce que tu crois
non absolument pas non je suis à thé
pratiquement
mais ça aussi c'est l'éducation ça aussi
c'est voilà c'est on est le fruit de
notre environnement donc par exemple
quand j'interroge quelqu'un dans la rue
je me dis pas oh le con il pense ça il
est con je me dis merde comment ça se
fait que dans sa vie il en est arrivé à
penser que les Arabes sont un danger et
les homosexuels sont pas normaux je me
dis j'ai envie de faire attention on va
aller discuter une heure tu vois et pas
le temps de le faire mais ça provoque
plus ça en moi
mais je rencontre pas de gens
haineux et même je vais dire franchement
même au meeting du Front national oui il
y en a évidemment il y a des mecs qui
ont théorisé le racisme et voilà qui
croit dur comme faire mais la plupart
des gens c'est juste des gens qui à qui
on a dû faut avoir peur de ça et puis
qu'on perd de ça en fait
je pense que
vous le voyez pas mais il fait un regard
hyper mystérieux
s'il te plaît
on en était à
les questions un peu chaudes avec les
humoristes il y a une question qui est
revenue souvent quand j'ai dit nous
avons dit que tu venais ta position sur
Dieudonnée
ouais c'était le gros débat parmi les
humoristes à un moment donné ma position
actuelle bah je sais pas si ça fait
longtemps j'ai pas regardé ce qu'il
faisait est-ce qu'il fait encore des
spectacles oui je crois bah là il nous
fait un spectacle avec Francis Lalanne
il se présente contre Valls
humoristique de présenter un gars qui a
mis une gifle un ministre
c'est la provoque un peu
ouais ben c'est dommage qui est tous
passif et gueuler bah Dieudonné pour si
je veux résumer le truc moi je trouve
c'est c'est un gâchis quoi ça c'est un
mec brillantissime dans le jeu dans
l'écriture
je connais pas psychologiquement
certainement il est il a fait les
mauvaises rencontres au mauvais moment
et il a basculé dans une espèce de
parano quoi c'est dommage c'est vrai que
c'est moi j'allais voir les spectacles
et tout au départ c'était vraiment
c'est pas original parce que j'ai pris
tout le monde le dit tu vois tu écris
tout seul
moi j'aime bien assumer j'aime bien
assumer c'est un peu de l'orgueil aussi
mais
parce que peut-être ça serait plus
efficace ou plus plus drôle si
j'écrivais à plusieurs il y a quand même
une intelligence collective qui existe
collaborative collaborative
donc mais je préfère assumer par exemple
Astier il a dit écrire seul ça donne
quelque chose de certainement très
maladroit mais d'extrêmement signé et je
préfère avoir un truc maladroit et
saigné que propre nickel et finalement
peut-être moins personnel
quand approche les politiques quand tu
vois Emmanuel Macron on va dire
sélectionner les journalistes qui vont
l'accompagner toi ça te provoque quoi en
tant que personne est-ce que tu penses
que c'est normal qu'un président
choisisse la cour qui suit
mais je crois il a mal géré son truc je
j'ai cru dire que ça stratégie de départ
était de dire je choisis les
journalistes qui sont spécialistes dans
le domaine et je pense qu'il a mal
anticipé le fait que les journalistes
seront incorporation qui se tient
beaucoup just ouais un peu et du coup
tout le monde a fait waouh qu'est-ce qui
se passe là et je pense que ça stratégie
qui est à la base c'est mon analyse je
sais pas ce qu'elle vaut mais cette
stratégie qui était plutôt de dire bah
oui regardez c'est normal on va prendre
les jeux si je vais au Mali par les
terrorisme je vais pas emmener mettons
l'équipe de Yann Barthès parce qu'ils
sont pas spécialistes de ça ça s'est
retourné contre lui je pense parce que
sur les déplacements de François
Hollande ou de certains ministres dans
nos anciennes colonies je crois qu'il y
avait des gens invité
complètement soutien à fond tous les
journalistes qui veulent aller suivre le
déplacement mais d'ailleurs de n'importe
qui à n'importe quel endroit en fait tu
penses que la liberté d'informer de dire
la réalité telle qu'elle est tu connais
moi un problème même tu vois les
journalistes qui suivent ce genre de
déplacement il y en a qui sont payés par
l'État pour faire ça enfin l'avion il
est affrété etc etc c'est c'est gênant
tu perds forcément en liberté
ou 50% des gens d'hôtel il y en a ouais
donc c'est c'est gênant ouais évidemment
c'est gênant même si tu perds alors leur
argument c'est de dire qu'ils perdent
pas en liberté que ça leur permet d'être
plus proche etc à la limite même si les
croix là-dessus tu perds quand même en
crédibilité
donc donc ouais c'est gênant évidemment
c'est gênant de toute façon sans vous
jetez des lauriers mais l'avenir de
journalistes c'est des gars comme vous
non mais si c'est vrai mais tant mieux
en fait
on veut pas être journaliste est-ce que
tu connais la charte de Munich
je rappelle moi le truc c'est une charte
des journalistes mais je sais plus les
droits du journaliste ça crée des
sources etc ça sort de là éviter de
faire passer dessous toujours garder son
indépendance
est-ce que tu penses que les
journalistes à l'heure actuelle bossent
suffisamment pour maintenir l'esprit
critique des gens sur la brèche
c'est pareil je suis un peu chaud avec
ça mais il faut définir les termes de la
question les journalistes ça veut rien
dire parce que Jean-Pierre Pernaut les
journalistes et Louis Pennel les
journalistes un reporter de guerre en
Syrie les journalistes ça s'appelle une
perte collatérale c'est ça
Jean-Pierre Pernaut ou le reporter de
guerre en Syrie
la truite
saumonie a dégagé
quand il s'appelle
Pujadas
pour les truites
de son éviction du 20h est-ce que tu
feras une blague sur sur Pujadas
avec une carte de presse mais j'ai
regardé l'émission politique
pour les humoristes c'était un sujet
au-delà de l'aspect capillaire du
personnage on a vu que tu as une grande
passion c'était chargé Valls
il me fascine ces gens me fascinent
quelque part mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui fait quand iron chez lui
quoi il est sur son canapé et qu'est-ce
qu'il pense de lui
j'ai envie de discuter avec Valls une
heure et lui dire mais attends
on va faire un point là sur ta vie tu
veux venir ici avec lui
non mais c'est je suis assez fasciné par
l'entêtement du du gars quoi
non mais là c'est le stop mais en plus
tu as plein de trucs à faire dans la vie
tu es sûr et tu es bon peut-être en
jardinage ou tu sais va ouvrir une ferme
pédagogique c'est la vie c'est pas que
avoir un petit bureau et puis avoir un
petit truc avec marqué mère ministre
j'avais les dire ça quoi Manu où elle
est quand même
donc je trouve ça désolant d'avant hyper
drôle parce que en tant que Maurice bon
bah merci c'était quatre chroniques
et en même temps ça m'intrigue beaucoup
tu tu fais comment pour t'informer tu
suis quel type de média
tu as des canaux particuliers tu t'es
fait un fil Facebook taillé
ça reste les canaux traditionnels quoi
l'AFP France Info et puis après dès que
je veux creuser un peu
j'ai peu non j'ai pas vraiment de site
de Médiapart si je suis abonné
sur image il faut que je m'abonne je me
suis pas abonné encore non fakir je l'ai
fakir reflet
non je suis tombé dessus deux trois fois
mais non
est-ce que tu gardes
je le mets entre guillemets est-ce que
tu gardes foi dans tes concitoyens ouais
pourquoi
parce que parce que on est et je me mets
dans victime de de notre environnement
on en revient à l'aspect déterministe
mais
tu trouves pas que c'est une
victimisation consentie
non quant moi j'ai la chance moi j'ai du
bol j'ai le temps de me poser on me paye
pour ça on paye pour prendre de la
distance et de donner mon avis sur des
trucs donc toute la journée je me dis ah
merde ça ça marche pas bien comment ça
pourrait marcher mieux ou comment je
pourrais dire aux gens que ça marche pas
bien c'est mon taf on paye pour ça c'est
un privilège incroyable merci
célibataire qui a trois enfants qui est
secrétaire qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
lui en veuille quel qu'elle soit pas
informé si BFM lui dit toute la journée
ou dès qu'elle rentre chez elle et
qu'elle met BFM les Arabes sont des
méchants les Arabes sont des méchants
qu'est-ce que tu veux je lui en veuille
non mais ils disent pas les Arabes sur
les méchants je suis bien conscient mais
il te mette un focus c'est pas très
compliqué à comment ça fonctionne tu as
la réalité qui est comme ça et eux ils
font ça ils ont regardé la réalité c'est
ça
tu pourras faire un gif
et j'habitais de faire de la radio alors
même si c'est filmé
qu'est-ce qu'on disait et ouais du coup
je peux pas lui en vouloir à cette
personne de de penser ce qu'elle pense
j'ai juste envie de lui dire non par
exemple
est-ce que tu te trouves bienveillant
quand tu tournes en ridicule Madame
Michu ou monsieur Michu qui a pas le
temps de réfléchir qui est sous pression
parce que les problèmes avec ses gamins
les problèmes de train les problèmes de
boulot problème de salaire problème
d'impôts
est-ce que des fois tu es pas
ça c'est une critique qu'on me fait
régulièrement et je
l'accepte quoi je la comprends en tout
cas je alors ça va peut-être te paraître
une astuce rhétorique mais je tourne pas
on ridicule madame Michou je tourne en
ridicule le raisonnement de Madame Michu
comme on peut tourner d'ailleurs je cite
pas je dis pas regarder madame monsieur
elle est con j'ai pas de vidéo donc on
va pas la reconnaître demain au marché
je cite les noms des gens qui ont des
responsabilités un député oui forcément
je vais dire c'est lui un porte-parole
de boîte ou mec qui bosse je sais pas
des fois je fais des salons machin là
oui c'est les gens qui représentent
quelque chose au-delà de leur propre
personne et de ce qu'il pense
est-ce que tu as déjà fait une chronique
sur Trump ouais de quelques-unes
sur Poutine non
non mais ça mériterait
hors Trump il y avait les Français avec
Trump j'avais fait quand il a été élu
j'avais été une soirée où il soutenait
plus ou moins Trump
plutôt plus que moi et
même peut-être c'est tout peut-être fait
que c'est le truc là est-ce que tu votes
ouais ouais
et tu votes depuis longtemps depuis que
j'ai le droit de vote qu'est-ce que tu
penses de l'abstentionnisme bah c'est
pareil je vais te dire la même réponse
qu'avant je comprends très bien
je trouve ça dommage parce que je pense
que dans ce système qui est évidemment
très très imparfait il y a la
possibilité de changer le système
imparfait donc je vote pour des gens par
exemple j'ai voté Mélenchon en premier
tour pour notamment la constitue parce
que c'est un mec qui avait dans son
programme voilà la volonté de changer ce
système là les institutions au deuxième
tour Macron non non Macron sans hésiter
ou rien c'est pas la même ça se vaut pas
quoi je sais bien j'entends un tout et
je n’ai pas fait de prosélytisme
en disant vous vendez pas compte les
grands-parents ils sont battus pour le
moment c'est pas des arguments ridicules
qui charge les abstentionnistes avec les
culpabilise tout ça quoi si tu veux j'ai
déjà fait des chroniques qui étaient un
peu comme ça mais parce que c'est mon
avis finalement donc voilà en fait un
média c'est une ligne éditoriale si ça
inéditoriale c'est celui-là moi je crois
pas du tout à l'objectivité des médias
mais je dis ça ça paraît waouh tu as
découvert la lune donc nous l'objectif
non on est froid comme des lames
évidemment que non mais non mais c'est
pas grave c'est pas de ta faute tu es
une personne qui pense qu'elle pense qui
est le fruit de tout ça
vous m'avez invité et vous avez vous
avez fait le choix de m'inviter c'est un
choix éditorial vous avez une éditoriale
vous n'êtes pas objectif personne n'est
objectif
notre processus de sélection de nos
invités
notre processus au départ c'est
collégial et ensuite on se fait on se
soumet à la vie de la communauté
donc la ligne éditoriale c'est un peu
comme la théorie du plancton chez nous
on est plein de petits plansctons et on
sera ensemble l'espace d'un instant pour
avancer et quand
les gens reviennent plus souvent si tu
en Meurice barré ou des choses comme ça
des sujets qui sont très éloignés de ce
qu'on fait d'habitude
on accepte parce que on a une
intelligence collective donc notre ligne
éditoriale est vachement influencée
aussi mais ça s'équilibre pas qu'elle
est pas influencée je dis que vous en
avez une et tant mieux ça s'équilibre
donc si c'est équilibré c'est une
inéditoriale ou c'est qu'est-ce que tu
peux peut-être répondre à nos
interrogations
ben non c'est comment ça s'est équilibré
c'est-à-dire que si tu as des avis de
partout on filtre tout on écoute tout le
monde c'est à dire que chez nous
tout le monde a le droit de parler que
tu sois du FN que tu sois islamiste
space islamiste pour les chats contre
les chats pour les licornes pour la
Russie pour les États-Unis tout le monde
s'écoute parce qu'on maintient un calme
au sein de notre communauté c'est à dire
que comme on est les plus durs de tous
les plus
endurcis
on a bien fait comprendre qu'on ne
supportait pas quand les gens
s'agressent
comment ça se passe toi tu filtres pas
les questions tu tu
ne vis que par ton expérience
personnelle et tu imprimes ta ligne
éditoriale dans tes chroniques ou dans
ton média ou moi bah oui moi oui c'est
sûr que oui la ligne éditoriale de
France Inter c'est quoi
aucune idée
je sais pas comment tu peux
pas sérieux
non je te promets j'écoute pas
donc je peux te dire Dominique ce matin
c'est plutôt très très très très libéral
mais le mec il bosse aux échos enfin tu
sais d'où il parle quoi
ça fait une chronique sur Mélenchon
c'est surtout la politique
internationale c'est un Maroc mais
qu'est-ce qui t'emmène dans la politique
internationale de Mélenchon
de fleurs sous le buste Fidel Castro
quoi parce que moi c'est les Castro je
serai en tôle en fait ou au mieux alors
je serai en bonne santé je saurais lire
et écrire mais je serai en tôle donc ça
me fait chier
[Musique]
ces ambiguïtés me font chier quoi
je comprends je comprends que le
bonhomme il est pas envie de se plier à
la doxa ambiante qui est de dire vive
les États-Unis d'Amérique ok mais bon
est-ce que pour ça tu es obligé d'être
ambigu ça me fait chier ouais ça m'a
fait chier là tu vas voir tu vas voir
pas de réaction sur j'ai l'habitude
qu'est-ce que tu penses du décodex
alors ça c'est le truc du monde j'ai pas
tellement suivi je suis nul par contre
on m'a invité mais vous saviez pas que
j'étais aussi nul
mais il faudrait faire un décodex du
décodex je pense
c'est une bonne idée
je vais te dire la même chose ce sont
des gens donc des êtres humains avec
leur subjectivité donc
forcément quand il juge un autre média
forcément il le font avec leur
subjectivité aussi donc il faudrait un
décodex du décodex quelle méthode de
travail tu ferais
bah j'irai voir qui fait le décodex et
tu peux pas les recevoir
on est dessus on va les recevoir à notre
façon
des pastilles c'est ça c'est les gens
qui jugent que ce soit les gens qui
jugent autant les homophobes que les
homos nous on juge personne et on
n'accepte pas que les gens jugent chacun
doit s'en durcir à son niveau pour
pouvoir avancer ensemble mais c'est
notre point de vue est-ce que ça reflète
le vote les gars
bon alors maintenant qu'on est en direct
mais tu juges enfin je sais pas c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis mais tu me
fais ton on est toujours en train de
juger ou de se juger ou se jauger
qu'on brasse tu vois tu as dû voir la
veille qu'on peut faire la veille
profonde qu'on peut faire sur les sujets
géopolitiques et je trouve ça
nous on fait ça depuis 2005 2006 on est
sorti du bois un peu plus tard après
mais on a bien suivi les guerres d'Irak
l'Afghanistan ainsi de suite le monde
ici c'est un peu vautré sur certains
sujets il sait même pas classé
donc ça nous a surpris si vous avez eu
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de se classer
en orange parce qu'il nous avait sorti
je dis ça de tête et je demande à la
communauté de le sourcer ce fameux
graphique avec les caves de Ben Laden
les ascenseurs les grands parkings les
dortoirs ainsi de suite dans les caves
de Tora-Bora
ta méthode de travail on a posé déjà
tu sécurité informatique ça te parle tu
es plutôt PC Mac
je suis plutôt Mac c'est de la merde non
aujourd'hui je vois bien du Coca-Cola
donc
ouais je suis plutôt Mac
mais parce que pour des raisons de de
comme ça m'intéresse pas j'ai besoin que
ça aille vite et quand je veux écrire un
truc que je puisse cliquer et puis que
je puisse vite écrire mon texte et en
fait un consommateur t'es pas un
utilisateur exactement tu as déjà subi
des aléas de la sécurité informatique
genre un mail qui saute
un petit vidange qui va bien non non bah
il y a eu une petite carte bleue qui te
fait défaut des choses comme ça
pour moi c'est il parle une langue
étrangère c'est compliqué il y a le bon
et le mauvais hacker je pense
que
je vais te poser des questions dessus
parce que c'est vrai que ça m'intéresse
pas le Black Cat c'est
le pirate
le White le blanc le chapeau blanc c'est
le Corsair et le grès hâte c'est celui
qui mixe un peu les deux un peu pour des
valeurs humanistes d'aider un peu ceux
qui sont un peu dans la galère ou des
choses comme ça oui donc c'est pas enfin
oui ça dépend ce que tu fais de ce
savoir là en fait qu'est-ce que tu
connais de la communauté est-ce que tu
as déjà vu
des choses tu as été dans des meetings
je t'invite nous t'invitons à la nuit du
HAC au mois de juin
j'ai vraiment chez une grosse grosse
quiche et en plus de ça ça m'intéresse
pas cette histoire de ransomware on m'a
expliqué vaguement mais c'est vraiment
ça ne parle pas
contre son
disque et ensuite il faut payer
l'antidote si tu me files
je suis passé nul que ça non mais ouais
non c'est si
je pourrais pas t'en dire plus la
composition du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que tu en penses
stratégiquement parlant c'est ultra
malin mais Macron a un mec très très
malin Macron et un mec qui joue qui fait
des coups oublier que ça c'était son taf
banquier et pas banquier de la Poste
quoi donc il continue c'est ça il est
c'est sa formation et puis ça amuse
beaucoup donc en termes de coût tactique
tu vois si tu siais si on voyait ça sur
je sais pas sur un risque que tu sais le
jeu de stratégie c'est notre jeu préféré
quand tu vois Beyrou alors si mes
souvenirs sont bons il est gardé saoules
et il est quand même mis en examen où il
est pour diffamation
ça passe
non
c'est pas ça ou tout court et puis c'est
le fait qu'il est dit moi je viens juste
pour filer un coup de patte sans
contrepartie et qu'après il est pas de
députés ici enfin moi je trouve ça plus
choquant que je pense que diffamation je
sais plus il a dit une connerie oui mais
c'est ça qui me choque le plus c'est
Bayero mais ça il y aurait beaucoup à
dire mais c'est vraiment la faillite de
la démocratie représentative de toute
façon quelle solution tu verrais pour
réajuster
moi j'étais assez pour une sixième
république avec une vraie constituante
avec je suis pas contre une dose de
tirage au sort
je connais pas assez pour m'aventurer
sur le terrain mais
ça me paraît un peu ce que j'ai entendu
en tout cas détiennent une fois me
paraît un peu radical oui pour le coup
ça l'est je suis pas très certain en
fait pour te dire que j'ai envie que les
gens que j'interroge tous les jours dans
la rue d'un coup se retrouve à devoir
voter des lois alors il va me dire que
c'est pas du tout ça que ça sera encadré
etc mais là on commence à rentrer du
coup dans le dans le fond des choses
c'est encadré par qui choisit les gens
qui encadrent et là est-ce qu'on
réapparaissent de retomber dans ces
mêmes rapports de force ce qu'il faut
réussir à atténuer c'est les rapports de
force quoi
donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse en fait je
pense qu'il faut cibler là après ça
c'est vieux comme le monde instruc t'as
entendu parler de ma voix non parti
politique c'est pas un parti politique
autant pour moi
c'est
les citoyens qui se regroupent pour
aussi faire les lois et ce surtout se
positionner pour devenir débuter d'une
façon tirer au sort il reçoivent une
formation par la communauté et ensuite
ils vont faire passer les lois que la
communauté lui faire monter est-ce que
c'est ça les gars
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas mal ça
me va
de toute façon le salut entre guillemets
va venir de là forcément parce que c'est
en train de se péter la gueule quand
même il y a de moins en moins de gens
qui votent et qui s'intéressent à ce qui
se passe autour d'eux
il y a une délices vraiment marquée
ils vont dire les politiques c'est tous
pourri en fait ils ont des raisons de le
dire en fait c'est pas juste des cons oh
oui vous ferez mieux de vous intéresser
c'est difficile pour ça je te dis je
sais pas pourquoi
c'est compliqué des dire à quelqu'un va
voter va voter si si c'est important ça
va changer la vie parce que
malheureusement
neuf fois sur 10 c'est pas le cas alors
après il y a l'autre côté qui est le
côté il faut pas non plus qu'on soit les
enfants gâtés
mais le meilleur moyen pour lutter
contre les deux les deux écueils c'est
ce que tu viens de dire ça me paraît
intéressant
qu'est-ce qu'on lui pose encore comme
question vous avez des questions les
gars est-ce qu'il y a des questions de
la communauté on attend vos questions
pendant que ça arrive sur notre nouvelle
notre nouveau petit écran il fait beau
et tous les gens ils sont ils sont pas
décris nous
à la communauté là tu nous vois
dickrivers ce que tu vois donc voilà
qu'est-ce que je vois des gens dans
l'ombre un peu c'est des gens qui aiment
pas travailler dans la lumière donc ça
c'est pas mal parce que bon comme ça ils
gardent un peu leur intégrité
je vois des gens motivés et qui
s'intéressent qui se sentent concernés
par ce qui se passe quoi ça ça me plaît
plutôt même voilà de quelques même de
quels idéologies ou de quelques bords
que ce soit ça m'a toujours intrigué que
les gens s'intéressent à ce qui se
passent autour d'eux je trouve ça plutôt
salutaire est-ce que tu as des questions
vont devenir ici est-ce que quoi est-ce
que tu as eu les questions avant de
venir ici les tiennes les nôtres
est-ce que tu as lu Noam Chomski
qu'est-ce que tu as lu de lui qu'est-ce
que tu as lu de lui
ça c'était très bien
[Musique]
est-ce que tu penses que le
micro-trottoir c'est réducteur oui à
fond ça c'est une question de la
communauté en fait je fais la même chose
que Jean-Pierre Pernaut sauf que lui se
dit journaliste et lui il va dire voilà
la réalité du monde voulait savoir ce
que les Français pensent de la grève
SNCF je vais aller sur un quai de gare
[Musique]
vous pensez quoi de la grève SNCF [__]
machin hop fin de reportage voilà les
Français posent donc la CGT c'est les
[__] bon voilà mais sous couvert de
neutralité je suis journaliste j'informe
le monde bon bah moi je dis je suis
humoriste
voilà ce que je pense et je vous voilà
comment on peut faire avec le même sujet
l'inverse en fait parce que vous faites
il y a un bon exemple de ça qui a été
c'est la contre-inquiète du bondi blog
sur le café de Sevran
exactement
il y a pas de problème d'égalité
homme-femme ok on parle de spéculer là
on n'est pas débile mais quand j'ai vu
ce reportage je me dis [__] c'est de
gonflé mon taf en fait mais moi je suis
humoriste moi tu vois oui évidemment je
peux en trouver trois blaireaux dans un
café
ou est-ce que tu Furnes ta vent est-ce
que tu sonnes les gens tu leur perds
leurs codes vestimentaire
il y a un profil faire un portrait en
haut au début quand tu commences tu as
toujours tendance à faire un peu facile
quoi qu'il arrive tu vois et en fait tu
t'aperçois que pas du tout tu peux non
il faut faire au pif
il faut vraiment faire au pif et puis
bon il y a peut-être si je veux juste à
peu préciser je fais souvent les marchés
parce que quand tu es dans la rue les
gens ils vont à l'endroit à un autre
donc clairement 9 fois sur 10 si on dit
bah j'ai pas le temps je vais là-bas
mais quand ils sont sur le marché bon
bah ils ont le temps et puis tu entends
un peu quand même des fois les Grandes
Gueules ou des gens entre qui parlent
politique ça ça peut m'aider quand même
mais sinon non faut faire au hasard
puisque c'est ça qui est rigolo les
lanceurs d'alerte
Dieu donne-moi trois noms de lanceur
d'alerte très connu
ce que tu veux en Suisse Luxembourg
moi
Gilles Mendes
et Stéphanie gibaudet
parce qu'elle soutenait Dupont-Aignan
Stéphanie Gibaud mais comme comme on a
arrêté les interviews politiques
d'ailleurs on prévient la communauté
étant donné qu'elle a mis un pied avec
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan elle est
considérée comme politique à nos yeux
alors on se pose la question parce qu'on
a lancé bon passons et en troisième un
quatrième vas-y un quatrième qui est
sorti hier de tôle
qui va changer de sexe
qu'est-ce que tu penses du fait que la
France n'est pas donnée l'asile
politique à ses lanceurs
ils sont députés quand même mais attends
ils ont députés pourquoi ils sont
députés
parce qu'ils étaient dans la cour
d'école et puis qu'ils arrivaient pas à
pécho de gonzesse et puis qu'ils ont une
faille affective mais il faut que
j'existe de la société tiens je peux
faire ça bah j'ai un petit talent
oratoire hop je me retrouve salle des
quatre colonnes
non mais c'est déprimant c'est ça je
vais pas faire une généralité mais il y
a beaucoup oui bon pourquoi autant
d'affaires de cul autant d'agressions
etc dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée ou
dans le milieu politique je parle du mec
qui lèche les pieds des autres là quand
il s'appelle
travail ouais ouais c'est moi je te
promets tu me dis c'est marrant parce
qu'on me pose souvent la question
comment tu fais mais moi ils me font de
la peine valse il me fait de la peine
j'ai envie de dire [__] mais merci je
ne suis pas Manuel Valls en fait
j'aurais pu être manuel Valls et les
gens que j'interroge pas tous j'aime
bien Isabelle Attar par exemple qui est
député qui fait le taf sur le numérique
elle est pas mal plutôt bien donc je dis
pas voilà pas tomber dans le machin
généralité mais bon après il y a une
question structurelle tout bêtement
pourquoi c'est ces gens-là qui sont
assez place là
c'est de la subordination de vote
en gros je te donne ton HLM parce que tu
vas te taire tu vas militer pour moi ou
je te promets des trucs
non mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
même c'est même au-delà de ça et d'un
truc très trivial de
mon vote contre l'amélioration de ta vie
immédiate au delà de ça quand tu
commences la politique au départ tu
crois et si tu veux monter dans un parti
si tu veux prendre des places bah ouais
mais tu es obligé de faire des compromis
donc en fait
si t'as pas vu le mime
donc en fait les gens qui sont les plus
motivés
et qui font ça vraiment pour leur
conviction ils vont ils vont se
décourager hyper rapidement donc ils
vont partir donc structurellement ne
reste plus qu'à la fin au haut de la
pyramide d'un parti le mec en a rien à
[__] en fait est quasiments plus un
idéologue du tout quasiment plus
quelqu'un qui réfléchit pourquoi il fait
ça ni comment faire avancer ses idées un
mec jusqu'à ou 1h qui a fait le plus de
compromis possible donc c'est pour ça
quand tu me dis ça pourquoi tu en veux
pas j'en veux pas ces gens-là j'en veux
à la structure je me dis merde faudrait
changer cette [__] de structure et je
vais me dire pour le bien de ces gens là
parce que peut-être direction
des bolas par exemple peut-être qu'il
faudra faire un spectacle de bolas et
les gens l'aimeront pour ça bon
j'exagère mais je sais pas peut-être ici
c'est un mec qui doit savoir faire des
trucs dans la vie Estrosi ou sinon
fait des trucs
pas va entraîner des gamins au foot tu
vois fais un truc où tu rentres chez toi
le soir et tu fais bon bah [__] c'est
cool quand même tu vois
parce que là tu rentres chez toi le soir
Emmanuel
vallsiotti tu dis ah bah c'est bien il y
a des migrants qui vont encore bien
dormir dehors ce soir tu es content de
ça vraiment tu es content il veut pas
faire dormir en dehors
qu'est-ce que tu penses du problème
migratoire
avec Cédric et roux de la vallée de la
Royale c'est fait froid dans le dos en
fait je pense que les générations
futures nous jugeront parce qu'on est
dans le coup c'est le mec qui a pris un
procès parce que parce que il facilitait
le
déplacement de certains migrants qu'il
est protégé du froid il enfiler des
freins il leur fil à bouffer
c'est un agriculteur et sa première
maison
[Musique]
en plus la France est respecte pas les
complètement nationaux parce que c'est
même interdit de laisser des mineurs
comme ça donc ouais c'est c'est tu sais
qu'aux États-Unis on va enfermer les
mineurs pour leur propre sécurité tu as
vu ce truc là les mineurs migrants en
prison pour leur propre sécurité mais
c'est pour ça que moi j'aime bien les
animaux aussi parce que l'Homo sapiens
c'est pas un animal qui
qui qui m'attire plus que ça je préfère
les orcs
j'aime bien les orques
d'un orque non c'est surtout pas en fait
j'ai pas envie de le faire chier alors
qu'il se démerde il fait pas chier moi
la question animale c'est un truc
vachement présent chez toi je mange pas
de viande ouais je mange pas de viande
des tournois
et c'est hyper bien c'est alors le seul
truc que je vous reproche que je
t'envoie c'est de m'avoir dit que
c'était un faux Doku tu m'as dit dans le
texto et du coup je suis parti dans
l'idée d'un folloculus direct bon je
pense que comme là c'est un peu un sujet
pas que je maîtrise mais je m'y
intéresse beaucoup je l'aurais vu est-ce
que tu connais la L214
je fais un spectacle pour aller
toute la tune à la sauce
de la recette ah ouais c'est ça marrant
parce que c'est au Café de la Gare et on
fait ça à la roue il y a une roue avec
les prix chacun de couleur
et donc je sais pas encore la recette
combien ça va être mais je refuse
là-dessus revenons aux migrants ouais
bah du coup voilà parce que j'ai à dire
c'est que je pense que les générations
futures vont nous nous jugerons quoi
c'est absolument scandaleux la manière
dont sont traité des gens comme ça il y
a un truc qui qui tu vois moi je suis
très sur les arguments et les failles
logiques etc les gens qui disent
être français ça série tout ça se mérite
là ça c'est les réacs tu vois un mec qui
a traversé 14 pays cachés dans un camion
est-ce que il y a un moment donné il
mérite pas à tout petit peu plus que toi
dont le seul mérite et d'avoir déchiré
le périnée de ta mère
tu vois c'est absurde parce qu'un jour
tu ferais une chronique à Mayotte
ça m'amuse j'ai toujours mon micro avec
moi dans mon sac et ça m'amuse d'aller
de faire des chroniques sur à peu près
tout et n'importe quel sujet faut juste
que moi j'ai un avis ce que je disais
tout à l'heure et une idée de rendre le
truc marrant donc à partir de là oui oui
il y a aucun sujet parce que par exemple
si tu te balades dans dans la jungle à
Mayotte ce qu'ils appellent la campagne
et que tu tombes mais année avec un con
dans Jouannet qui fait pousser des
tomates avec quelques uns qui ont la
lèpre
et que tu discutes avec eux tu serais
capable de faire une chronique sur eux
comment faire rigoler avec la lèpre il y
a un petit il y a un petit challenge
mais ouais ouais pourquoi pas faire
rigoler avec les
dessus et il balance des offrandes au
moment de passer la barrière de corail
pour éviter de se bouffer ou de se
chauffer par la PAF
on arrive à la fin alors attends je
regarde les questions
tu interroges combien de personnes pour
ta chronique
ça dépend les chroniques mais si je veux
être un peu est-ce que tu sélectionnes
les pires ah oui évidemment oui bah oui
je passe à l'antenne oui oui je
sélectionne les pires sa mère arrivait
peut-être une ou deux fois de pas les
passer parce que c'était même plus
marrant tellement c'était soit raciste
je crois que c'est un Front national il
y avait vraiment un mec ou qui avait dit
les Arabes c'est des chiens ou un truc
comme ça ou si j'ai eu pas mal de tobira
vraiment des insultes surtout bien mais
du coup ça rendait tu vois juste un mec
qui insulte c'est pas
tu fais quoi dans 10 ans je m'en fous
aucune idée
tu vis au jour le jour
comment ça s'est passé il est il est de
l'air et du vent c'est ça
ultra sincère en fait alors
j'ai capable de composer une opéra à mon
avis il écrit avec ses tripes
donc ouais bah il disait il fait une
initiale ces initiative citoyenne dans
son truc 100% donc non non mais je Tu
voterai pour lui ou tu veux très valse
pour le artistiquement ça doit être
marrant de mettre déjà j'ai mis un
bulletin Macron dans une urne c'est un
peu une performance artistique si tu
veux ça c'est de l'art contemporain
pour voter Valls
Gilbert Collard je vois très Manuel
Valls
est-ce que
attends
à l'antenne et bien je est-ce que tu
vois la corrélation entre le temps de
passage à l'antenne et et les résultats
sur les élections des différents
candidats genre Macron qui a jamais été
élu
qui a un temps d'antenne supérieur à
d'autres alors que c'est le saint
qui contrôle le temps de parution et qui
dit voilà si vous n'êtes pas élu ou quoi
que ce soit vous représentez
la question d'avant sur combien de
personnes d'interrolls je voulais juste
dire c'est un espèce de ratio de 1 sur 3
de la rue comme ça mais après quand tu
vas à meeting Front national c'est c'est
un sur deux quasi voir un sur un et donc
mais quand c'est un sujet on va dire
global par exemple j'ai fait cette
semaine qu'est-ce que les Français ils
pensent de Edouard Philippe
donc j'ai été dans le 17e faire un
marché dans le 17e là je pensais un sur
trois tu vois environ voilà alors c'est
toujours les questions Macron c'est
toujours les questions de la communauté
je termine Macron je t'en Macron parce
que tu m'as pas posé cette question mais
sur le ton le ton de passage à l'antenne
il est répercussions sur les les sur le
le pourcentage aux élections
regardez les deux courbes je pense qu'à
mon avis ça se sentiment lié bah ouais
je crois
je les ai pas sous les yeux mais il me
semble que oui Macron c'est un mec qui
pareil pour les historiens c'est un mec
intéressant parce que je crois qu'il
résume hyper bien son époque quoi c'est
il maîtrise un génie de la communication
il maîtrise complètement les codes de la
communication je suis assez d'accord
avec je pense évidemment vous connaissez
usule qui a fait ouais je suis assez
d'accord avec ça une des dernières
vidéos qu'il a fait
sur Macron et son rapport aux médias on
a toujours tendance à dire c'est les
médias qui ont propulsé Macron et le
fait une vidéo en disant que c'est
Macron qui s'était servi des médias
d'une manière
ultra habile et moi je suis plutôt
d'accord avec ça en plus pour travailler
dans un média même si je suis pas la
rédac je vois bien qu'il y a pas de
réunion secrète pour dire voilà il faut
faire monter Macron regardez on va faire
si on va faire ça
mais par contre le mec arrive bien
ultra séducteur donc donc il sait y
faire avec ça et c'est un génie de la
com ouais mais c'est du vide absolu mais
c'est ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure ça me
fait des coups
Henri Ermont ça te parle non est-ce que
est-ce que tu pourrais nous donner pour
toi le nom d'un journaliste qui
représente parfaitement sa profession
notre prochain invité journaliste vas-y
dis-le donne-nous tu veux qu'on passe
qui
non mais il y en a pas un mais tous les
gens qui bossent qui tu verrais à ta
place là
[__] c'est une grosse responsabilité
méfie-toi
le prix Albert Londres tu connais le
prix Albert London
France cette année j'ai pas eu tu sais
qu'on a reçu le on a reçu un Prix Albert
Londres sur la faire far well la faire
faroel c'est Vladimir vetroff
l'équivalent du Snowden mais russe
l'affaire oui dans le sens où c'est des
questions qui nous qui nous touchent
beaucoup
et puis de fil en aiguille en fait on
l'a fait venir mais on savait pas qu'il
était déjà appris Albert Londres mais on
l'a fait venir pour parler de
l'indépendance journalistique c'est
le directeur d'information de France
télévisions.com
donc question de la communauté que je ne
comprends pas c'est pas grave je vais la
lire quand même la liste noire de Cohen
il faut lui demander moi je sais pas moi
je sais pas faut les demander à lui
d'accord je sais pas s'il en a une fin
c'est toujours pareil ça veut dire non
mais c'est intéressant comme question
quand même mais évidemment tu as invité
à une émission t'invite t'invite quitter
envie d'inviter en fait qui tu verras à
ta place ah oui je t'ai pas répondu
c'est ça
moi je ferais toi j'inviterai à
ouais ouais
c'est une sorte de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
ça pour relancer la machine
j'inviterai un étudiant en première
année d'école de journaliste
tu prends le major ou le dernier de la
classe
j'en ai rien à [__] du classement j'en
prends au pif au pif
de quelle école je m'en fous un mec qui
est ou une nana d'ailleurs
n'importe quelle école quelqu'un qui tu
lui posera quoi comme question
quelle volonté il a et
qu'est-ce qui pense pouvoir faire mieux
que ce qui n'est fait en ce moment ou ce
qui n'a déjà été fait
ça tu veux pas que je te fasse ton taf
pour la prochaine c'est notre taf
alors ah tiens deux questions que nous
on maîtrise mais que tu vas pas
peut-être ça c'est des questions
hardcore pour lui parce que je suis con
non mais c'est des réseaux d'influence
on connaît les deux personnellement et
on va te les poser quand même le build
delberg ça te parle
sous quelle langue c'est le parle sur le
genre la grande conspiration où ça te
parle résoudre d'influence il me tank
ainsi de suite
c'est comme le siècle exactement
c'est la deuxième question c'est ça
sinon c'était ensuite le deuxième mot
après la virgule c'était Bill dolbergon
c'est plus un peu plus balaise que
bildleberg c'est un truc de vieux le
truc le vraiment ça c'est notre opinion
personnelle si vous m'arrêter
le siècle c'est un truc de vieux attends
faire le pied de gris derrière tu les
vois
c'est un peu plus croustillant
et la Trilatérale aussi pour toi c'est à
bannir complètement évidemment
passer à bannir tu peux c'est difficile
d'interdire des gens de se réunir quoi
on est plus sous Napoléon
je te parle des raisons d'influence pas
transparent pas les réunions les
réunions ils font ce qu'ils veulent
est-ce que est-ce que quand tu vois des
journalistes sur
Internet
demander de la transparence
autre question de la communauté
voilà c'est compliqué de répondre non
comment tu veux répondre dans un truc
là-dedans c'est bien qu'il y ait des
gens qui se réunissent sans qu'on sache
rien de ce qu'ils se dise et qui en plus
représentent tous les postes de pouvoir
c'est chaud à des potes va bien être
l'avocat intellectuellement c'est
stimulant mais là chaud nous nous avons
besoin de se parler ces gens-là à la
Trilatérale la trilatéralement vu qu'on
est en direct on s'en fout
la Trilatérale on en connaît des 13
puissants et très influents j'ai bossé
sur la réévaluation des intérêts vitaux
des États-Unis
[Musique]
le pilote du groupe de travail c'était
l'ancien ambassadeur de France à
Washington
première réunion façon Mad Men tu vois
parce que la série maintenant donc
exactement le même type de réunion façon
madmen première réunion j'ai failli leur
lancer la table à la gueule
mais bon passons
aussi
parce que les gros barbus qui crèvent la
faute en fait c'est plus les enfants
c'est pas ça c'est un choix le gamin il
a rien il a rien demandé parce que le
gros barbu forcément
c'est un choix c'est-à-dire que on
traite les terroristes c'est en général
les terroristes c'est toujours l'armée
la plus faible dans l'histoire
est-ce qu'il se sentiraient de créer un
groupe d'influence pour améliorer la
société virgule s'organiser autour de
stratégie etc etc
les questions beaucoup de langues qui
m'ennuient dans cette phrase mais alors
je te le répète j'ai compris la question
je pense
ça dépendra du but en fait genre est-ce
que tu créerais un comité Orwell de
l'humour
mais je connais pas son travail donc
c'est compliqué pour moi ce serait très
intéressant de te faire échanger avec
elle tu serais d'accord
pourquoi ouais
pourquoi pas ça me dérange pas à quelle
heure
avec qui tu discuterais pas non personne
personne
on arrive des messages qui commençaient
par espèce de fils de [__] et qui
terminait par merci j'ai déjà eu des
messages où les gens s'excusaient de
m'avoir insulter parce que ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de trouver le
dénominateur commun le terrain
d'antanque mais juste pour finir parce
que comme votre truc c'est aussi un peu
les médias tout ça
tu as beaucoup j'ai beaucoup de mails
qui disent enfin beaucoup les mails de
gens qui m'envoient des trucs qui
m'aiment pas il y a pas mal de tu fais
partie du système etc bah oui je suis
sur France Inter a priori t'as rien
inventé donc je comprends la critique de
des médias dominants et moi je leur dis
mais moi je crois je suis d'accord avec
vous là dessus par contre je comprends
pas pourquoi vous avez pas la même
critique sur le site conspiration.com
qui pour vous donne la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé
mondiales ou j'en sais rien des sites
nous on les scanne c'est à dire que on
essaie de voir ce qui sortent au milieu
de cet océan de conneries
de temps en temps il lève des trucs
parano de conspirationnisme pendant des
années des années parce qu'on disait que
tout le monde était un petit
ressentiment sur le mot conspirationnel
parce que c'est là où tu as décroché tu
ne m'écoutais plus c'est ça donc je
reprends ma mon raisonnement il faut
avoir le même esprit critique sur les
médias 2000 il faut avoir un esprit
critique sur ce qu'on dit
qui te dit quel intérêt aurait la
personne qui te dit ça à le dire et
pourquoi elle te le dis à ce moment-là
voilà c'est pas compliqué mais que ça
soit
[Musique]
un site et X ou Y sur Internet une info
que tu as vu passer ou que ça soit le
rang Delahousse
il faut avoir et chronique aussi tout
bon on arrive à la fin pardon je me suis
un peu énervé à la fin c'est pour faire
du maximum d'énervement la dernière
question qu'on pose toujours à nous
inviter que tu as eu parce que tu sais
pertinemment que à la fin de nos
vidéos on dit laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
avant ça il y a est-ce que tu as une
question à nous poser
pourquoi vous êtes un vous présentez
comme un collectif
pourquoi il y a que toi qui parle parce
qu'il y a qu'un seul micro et il y a une
vraie réponse ça ou pas
c'est une bonne question je vais leur
poser vous voulez parler qui est-ce qui
veut le micro tu veux parler
parce qu'il a il a le répondant qu'il
faut et que on se sent pas forcément
prêt encore pour prendre le micro mais
pourquoi pas un jour on fera passer le
micro mais il y a déjà eu des
intervenants autres que que la personne
qui tient le micro d'habitude
OK
donc voilà ça répond à ta question bah
ouais tu en as peut-être une autre
pourquoi elle était pas bien ma question
non
un conseil pour les jeunes
les collectifs très horizontaux où il y
a quand même une forte personnalité qui
est lead nous nous on n'a pas de leader
on n'a pas de patron
par exemple
de manager c'est une phase de Macron ça
tu sais nous c'est la société civile et
tout
d'un Francis Lalanne c'est pour ça
comment vous voyez votre développement
futur est-ce que vous pensez qu'à terme
vous allez prendre la place qu'occupe
aujourd'hui les médias
on est bien sur Internet
d'importance est-ce que vous pensez que
un jour vous battrez le JT de de France
2 en nombre
téléspectateurs on fait un demi-tiseur
ou pas enfin demi-seur un demi attends
il faut jouer on fait un demi bon
tu as croisé
on est en train de te préparer un truc
pour la communauté quand on va revenir
on va tous les calmer OK
Google
est-ce que non parce que
tu as toi perso là c'est vraiment ça
reste toi tu as une colère
que tu
as fait comme ça
je te sens en colère contre un truc et
ton moyen de la canaliser c'est de faire
ce que tu fais
c'était un reformule ta question
est-ce que tu penses que je suis en
colère
parce que j'ai l'air en colère oui oui
et ben pour répondre tout à fait oui
ouais mais finalement c'est un peu mon
cas aussi on est on est très en colère
et on le on le traite cette colère au
lieu d'aller faire de la boxe on peut
aussi faire de la boxe est-ce que tu as
lu Karl vonclos vite non de la guerre
est-ce que ça te parle ah ouais ouais
mais alors non est-ce que tu as lu
zoomzu
on est en colère parce que nous on vit
sur Internet on est une partie sur
Internet l'internet c'est la moitié de
notre cerveau ou c'est notre deuxième
cerveau c'est notre
deuxième rapport à les hauts
interactions ça fait depuis très très
longtemps qu'on est depuis la création
d'Internet pratiquement du moins la
démocratisation d'internet on est en
colère parce qu'on voit passer toute la
misère du monde et que ça monte en
puissance
que les pouvoirs politiques sont soit
démunies soit
ils ont pas envie de travailler ils sont
pas payés assez cher tu comprends
[Musique]
de faire une stratégie de faire un
bateau de guerre
c'est à dire que ils nous prennent pour
des débiles mentaux on va leur montrer
que un on sait très bien s'informer deux
qu'on a des réseaux partout trois que on
est transverses avec énormément de
cercles et qui ont les emmerde nous on a
des questions et personne n'y répondent
donc autant le faire allez les chercher
c'est pour ça tout à l'heure j'ai dit
que l'avenir c'était sur comme vous et
tant mieux
tu veux d'autres questions à nous poser
avant d'aller faire la fête des voisins
avec nous je tiens
non j'en ai plus là non non merci
aux jeunes génération il a déjà dit NON
NON lâche un autre conseil de vidéo
parce que c'est pas de moi mais c'est de
Nietzsche devenir qui vous êtes quoi
c'est à dire soyez le plus proche de de
ce que vous êtes et de ce pourquoi vous
faites les choses
essayer de faire le moins possible de
compromis avec les autres avec vous-même
je dirais c'est un peu les Francis
Lalanne on pige ou pas c'est presque du
Mâcon fait gaffe non mais je pense que
le meilleur moyen
d'être bien dans ses baskets c'est ça
quoi le c'est peut-être même le sol si
tu es sur ton chemin
quelqu'un vient de dire hey ton chemin
c'est de la merde tu t'en fous c'est
trop en fait c'est hyper désagréable
d'être détesté pour un truc que tu es
pas ou d'être adoré pour un truc que tu
es pas si par exemple demain je fais la
ferme des célébrités je sais pas quoi et
du coup tout le monde de la rue vient me
dire génial on t'adore parce que quand
tu as vu mais je serais hyper malheureux
voilà de même si je fais la ferme des
célébrités qu'on me dit espèce de conte
a été nul tu as mis un coup de pelle à
Loana je serais hyper malheureux alors
que si demain on vient me dire dis non
ou comme ça m'arrive dis-moi ta
chronique aujourd'hui c'était bien de la
merde je fais ah ok alors explique-moi
pourquoi tu trouves ça de la merde parce
que peut-être que tu as raison en fait
peut-être c'était de la merde ou que
j'ai mal évidemment j'ai pas c'est pas
parfait et ça ça m'intéresse parce que
je m'en fous je sais que c'est ça que je
veux faire je suis à la bonne place pour
moi et là on peut discuter du coup
calmement tranquillement objecture
d'échange
c'est pas mal ça
merci
c'est un collectif aussi
elles sont toutes occupées
ça marche c'est bon
[Musique]